we are back the families are back
we're here again
no infighting yet
no beefing
all love in the family all loving the
family my dad got a camera give a shout
out to gary ladies and gentlemen
gary
[Music]
stand up gary yeah stand up baby stand
up gary
today's episode is sponsored by credit
karma magic spoon mvmt movement and
bright sellers
[Applause]
yeah shredder
so um
we have a great show planned today we
are going to be doing me and my mom my
mom has spent her whole career as a
hairdresser
yeah how long were you at a hairdresser
something like 42 43 years you feel that
you're confident with the sip of
scissors yes
one of the best would you say
i'd say i'm in the top
ten percent i mean i did
being modest yeah we could go higher
than that no i mean you know there's a
lot of hairdressers out there made a
good living i made a very good living so
what i'm leading to is that me and my
mom are going to have a hair cut off
we've got a mannequin
and we're going to be doing the caring
what that's the haircut we'll be
competing it's going to be really
embarrassing when your son with no
experience does a better caring haircut
than you
well okay we'll see
that's a lot of pressure
nah it's a piece of cake you better be
worried
can i make the karen a little better can
i give it a twist of my own yeah yeah
well yeah
make it look ugly no you make it
beautiful you make it your you girl okay
um and then also coming up we've got
mike okay so i don't know if you guys
followed the creep show drama
that was a that was a tough one to
untangle for me but luckily we have my
parents here to explain the creep show
drama and we have no it's like three
pages of pages
yeah last time i used one page this is
good well i think you need from what
i've tried every video about the creep
show thing is like two hours long how
many videos did you guys watch well i
watched dad did his own research oh you
guys researched independently oh yeah we
always research independently because
dad's always watching some baseball game
or something on
independent studies always and it turns
out creep shows actually a person yeah
who knew shannon also incidentally also
a creep yeah as well and a show
so anyway we've got so much fun stuff
coming up but first before we get into
all that dad
i have some bad news for you wait hold
on my mom's calling i gotta go
your mom
dad so
you had claimed previously that you had
only three porn followers
uh
i see where we're going uh unfortu which
was you know unfortunately an indirect
challenge
to everybody to count the actual
uh fault do you want to make a um
do you want to clarify at all
do you want to make uh
do you want to amend your estimate
before i show the real number oh you
actually have a real number oh yeah oh
yeah oh lord the the
original discussion i think was only
people not entities oh absolutely
another word
splitting
i don't think so well it's all even if
you do say three
it's way more okay
of people go ahead but all of them
combined i will say in my feeble defense
that um once i went back there and and
look through there
you know some of those have been on
there since the invention of twitter i
think they don't they don't pop up on
your on your feed or anything yeah they
were on there when i opened my twitter
account i think no oh apparently i see
they pre-loaded they burned those into
your twitter yeah i
so at that point i think i had about
1200 twitter followers 1200 twitter oh i
thought you wanted to say something else
i had a second heart attack and you know
like a lot of people that follow a lot
of people you might only see tweets from
someone you follow once a year all right
what's the number
um well i have gone through and revised
those oh you've unfollowed some was yeah
okay i unfollowed a bunch of irrelevant
people
so i know uh
some of the porn accounts are relevant
they are i'm yeah proud of some of them
okay okay good
reach out to me for more information on
that if you desire but no don't no i
don't no stop that i don't want you
having a conversation with people about
your favorite porn accounts
no not people
oh what did you mean
the the uh recipients the tweeters
themselves okay anyway
i've revised it down
uh got rid of a bunch of relevant ones i
know it was up in the 70s allegedly
and as i said on the last show
i'm not good at counting so uh that was
really bad at counting
you got a lot of love from sex workers
though saying hey gary sex positive i
did he did i did there i got uh a lot
more followers in the sex worker
industry none of them were people that i
was following at that point but did you
follow them back um no no i'm in enough
trouble already
i did appreciate their follow and uh
you know including them my my twitter
look i'm sex positive too just not when
it comes to my dad i'm sex negative when
it comes to my dad everyone else
sex workers god bless but with my dad no
chastity belt
i don't want any of that i don't want to
know about any of that understandable
what was the number okay so you want the
real number yeah okay so drum roll
my dad said 70.
there was some conflicting numbers i
think because my dad was in the process
of unfollowing them
but the reports that i've had range
between 112 and
134 accounts wow
oh my
which constitutes about 10
roughly of your followers
of your follows
right i'm calling [ __ ] on that oh no
that's that's that's i have here dad
come look at the screen right now come
here come look at this
i knew you'd try to call me out on this
we have screen shots of every
i knew you would try to dispute this so
we came right
somebody put this together
yeah my dad is being litigated i'm for
one person i thought was funny was like
damn can't y'all just let gary beat his
meat in peace
[Laughter]
well
i i think which i i respect too but i
think it's just funny twitter isn't porn
and [ __ ]
twitter i've seen vile [ __ ] on porn you
can show anything on twitter
twitter is porn
it's a gateway to porn
well but just
following someone
isn't getting you into porn necessarily
unless you okay
what is this argument um
the argument is
i i don't think you could find any of
those uh
interactions except maybe
five where i've actually tweeted
something back it's all just randomly
grabbing people that i that i had
followed or following yeah and
taking something from them but there's
no interactions there so i would say
uh i don't i'm not accusing you of
interacting with anybody so
i plead not guilty okay
of being a pervert i guess i don't know
what else
just a normal healthy
uh i mean how old are you now
70 and you're still i mean at it so god
bless i guess
yeah
ask your mother what she thinks stop i'm
not asking mom what she don't ask her
don't ask me what do you think what does
that mean
never mind
moving right along
when the bit goes too
far yeah 114 that was too far you know
there was um yeah
let's not even let's not even go into
your alt account to be honest yeah let's
not let's let's also my and my and gary
news my dad was arguing with people in
the comments from the past video yes he
does that
which is kind of i have to say i think
it's funny you do that and it's fine but
it's kind of like a cardinal rule of
being on the internet that you don't
argue with people in the comments that
being said you do you i love it for you
and um here's some of the choice ones
because they're pretty funny i mean
do you feel like you have any fulfilling
uh conversations in the youtube comments
sometimes and i didn't really
go back at anyone except the
alleged cosmetology or plastic surgery
person
a lot more of my comments were just
thank you to people and i was really
stunned by the number of people who
wrote such nice things about it that's
nice watching us had helped them with
their family issues or just made them
feel good and yeah some people really
just wrote some heartfelt stuff yeah
that was really nice a lot of those
people you know i thank personally
um so there was a lot more of that than
arguing with people
i agree well i mean just well right and
of course i'm interested in the argument
of course yeah
here's one um your mom needs to divorce
that disrespectful asset that's cheating
well we disagree that's not cheating
yeah exactly that's not that's a death
yeah i can't eat that i have good eyes i
have wow the one thing i can say for
myself is that i have good good vision
well i it's just a big blur thank you
everybody i have i have a fantastic
vision that's the one thing i could pat
myself on the back yeah wait till you're
50. i don't know which side that comes
from i mean i still don't have glasses
yeah because you both have bad vision
right i didn't wear glasses until i was
50. oh really yeah then your eyes just
and then all of a sudden my eyes went
because you have really bad eyes she
needed to wear glasses no no no no mine
was about 20. i just didn't wear them
yeah
i mean i i don't think my vision has got
like noticeably worse
uh either so i mean i'm 36 now and my
vision's still good so knock on blood i
guess
anyway dad responds what's cheating
exactly follow someone on twitter wow
that's a low bar how's your marriage
doing
slam dunk
toby
nice one did they do they respond when
you dunk on them like that usually not
and you know we all were so clever and
write best
i mean i don't think these people ever
dreamed that the gary klein would be
coming back with a alley-oop on them
that's correct do you think they know
that it's really you i think a lot of
people think it's a fake i've got two
different twitter handles actually one
is gary klein the other is gary bruin
and i i had some people looking at gary
bruin and not thinking oh yeah maybe
that's what youtube uh you're gabriel on
youtube so people didn't think it was me
and some of them that doubted i said yes
it's me and i should probably
change that to gary k bruin or something
you need to just submit
if you write your social security number
or your driver's id or something maybe
that would let them know that it's real
all right that's a good idea date of
birth mother's day all that stuff okay
someone else said good luck with all
that merch
such a feeble little left weirdo such a
coward oh is that that's just a general
insight to all of us
dad came on top he said way to think for
yourself
yeah boom
slam dunk how's that feel [ __ ]
and then i i don't know how this
happened but you sent another response
to the same person good luck with all
that merch such a feeble left weirdo
such a coward and then dad came out with
the second
insult because the first time wasn't
good enough he said
oh this is a good one actually i'm a
brilliant political thinker with a ba in
political science from ucla sorry to
disappoint you
humblebrag d oh nothing humble about
that yeah right do you think you're a
brilliant political thinker that's
fantastic i do not
but compared to that person yes compared
to him you are relative yeah you are
that's [ __ ] that's so awesome and i
do have a ba no that's true yeah
absolutely you do oh gary you're so cute
you too that's a fantastic response
though i do love that
that could almost be a copy pasta
response dan don't you think
[Music]
um
ethan's dad is kind of creepy and rude
well that i disagree with i don't think
you're i don't think you're rude
[Laughter]
thanks for clarifying yeah we know how
you feel about the creepy part already
as ham oh here comes dad with hamilton
quotes get the [ __ ] out the way
as hamilton said i'm not stupid maybe
over your head i do have a ba from ucla
you're throwing it use that ucla thing
around oh yeah
well that's from
i i'm on twitter a lot politically
not just with porno stars but with
actual people involved in politics and
sometimes they overlap i've honed my
skills uh coming back at people like
that but what do you mean as hamilton
said i'm not stupid well i think
that
tied into the one you just said about us
being stupid i don't know how what was
disney
friend he said i'm not stupid he wanted
to know how he could he could graduate
no someone there called called me stupid
or called us stupid oh the person said
he's just funny stupid old man right
okay so so i'm okay hamilton said i'm
not stupid okay interesting
because a lot of people probably say i'm
not stupid
hamilton being the most famous right
[Laughter]
anyway got him
uh here's another one it says i did a
quick count
gary follows 93 different porn related
blah blah blah
porn producers
magazines so you know the whole slew of
them
um
award accounts let me know if anyone
else has done a count as i may have
missed more and then gary comes back who
asked you
yeah who asked him find your own clients
in the comments i love that
i don't care if anyone i don't know if
anyone cares but i'm gonna need a lot
less of ethan's dad and a lot more of
ethan's mom that's that is not just for
the record that is not supported people
love both of you yeah
i admire that person's good taste
actually but my dad responded that's
fair
[Laughter]
and then of course there's another
rambling one about dads ethan's dad
wants to be a part of the show blah blah
blah blah and then you responded at
least i can spell
and eternal uh the internal uh slam dunk
yeah can we talk to your can't spell
your right
um
gary cline thinks he's the funniest
person in the room jealous
[Laughter]
someone said dad has definitely had some
affairs do i know you
my dad responded
so there you go
and then the one that actually tipped me
off to this whole thing was there was
some lady
um
who was insisting that my mom has had
plastic surgery and then my dad got into
a whole big heated exchange with them
wow i couldn't i think she erased her
comments so we were unable to really i
only have this screenshot you sent me
whenever you're saying at your guys's
house
but this person was insisting they said
i'm a cosmetic or i'm a plasti or i work
at a plastic in the field
and she says there's no way donna
[Laughter]
she says here
how absurd she says it's so absurdly
common these procedures are done
nowadays it's not irony you spot it you
got it after working nearly eight years
in plastic surgery i can tell if people
had anti-aging work done once i know
their age i'm only i'm only able to see
glimpses of it um
but this person is insisting that you
have plastic surgery mom
well what did they what work did they
claim she has done uh botox face peels
veneers ears veneers i never even wore
braces
and i said the only work she gets done
is dyeing her hair yeah i did my hair i
mean i was just indignant at
this person suggesting they know better
than i what work she's got done and then
the next step in defending it was well i
see these women they hide it they
schedule vacations oh yeah right secrets
and it's like what kind of relationship
do these people have like if mom wanted
to say
i'm getting plastic surgeons like all
right where are we going you know i
would support her 100 so no you wouldn't
it cost too much money oh burn i love to
hear that
but
you know she doesn't need it
no one even believes she's the amazing
go ahead do you have plastic surgery i
have no plastic surgery but how do you
look so good at your age what's your
secret a lot of you know i look at the
mirror and i go oh my god i've got jowls
i've got you know wrinkles i don't know
what you guys are looking at like 65 now
i'll be 66 in october 66
yeah i mean all my girlfriends look like
me
no
no but let let me get a look at you so
what's yours what's your routine people
want to know what's your beauty routine
okay girls i will tell you my because my
question is not that nice
well you got hair on your face no but
like a heart
like i have blackheads and [ __ ] like you
don't even have black [ __ ] she's got the
olive complexion thing going there
my secret is
when you wash your face
use a washcloth
wow
that reminds me i don't know how many
people watch one wow i don't know how
many people watch one punch man but
should i go there dan
maybe not no it's true when you use a
washcloth
it you know it it takes all the dry skin
off your face and also
you know years ago when men used to go
to the barber to get their hair cut and
they would get a shave and then the
barbers used to put these oops these hot
towels and wrap them around
their face because it opens up your
pores and it makes your hair well i
don't have any hair on my face but it
opens up your pores
okay
washcloth sales are about to boom
no it's true you use a washcloth every
night yeah and you you put warm water on
it and you just gently rub really hot
water and and and if if women can use
soap
oh yeah okay so i use soap so what
process do you use the soap
she loves on the washcloth
no actually i i lather my hands and i
wash my face and then i rinse my face
off what kind of stuff do you use i
can i tell the product yes please the
people
i love lush products so lush makes
facial wash well i just use their
regular body so oh you mom you're just
flexing on people my mom uses body soap
on her face no no no they have face so
they have face soap too that i i use
sometimes would your complexion always
really
like this yeah
no i went through puberty just like all
the other
women it's always been good i mean so
many people
you know when you're a teenager you look
forward to not being in a tanger so you
get rid of pimples and a lot of adults
continue to have problems adult acne but
she's never well you know what problem
like that
a lot of teenagers have a habit when
they have breakouts or blackheads
they even make these tools where you can
squeeze it out
don't do that
just take
just take your washcloth and put it on
really hot
under hot water
and then just put it on your affected
area
and it again it opens up the pore
donna there's a call for you from dr
pimple popper oh god my girlfriend
watches that show that's right he
disagrees with you yeah it sounds the
concept is disgusting so we're basically
it's warm water washcloth gently
exfoliating yeah yeah i do that with my
back too because a lot of a lot of women
no my back is fine but you're saying the
washcloth help but yeah if you you know
it prevents anything
and i do use moisturizer under my eyes
only under your eyes yeah because i i
you don't moisturize your face no i
don't it makes me break out
wow so only under the eyes only under
the eyes interesting and is it some
fancy moisturizer or is it just like uh
well whatever dad gets at costco oh my
god
she's just using kirkland moisturized
body moisture
no not body moisturizer it's it's for
but i feel like people thought that
there was like some secret health care
thing and there is
washcloth okay
the secret really is
being married to a wonderful supporting
husband for many many years and living a
stress-free life oh my god you know uh
well people were saying we should do
some product to to sell i think we
should just sell a washcloth
that'd be fantastic teddy freshwater
i'm telling you the washcloth is the
secret interesting that's good advice i
mean hey
some people say i think some people
might say that it's too um
it's too rough on the skin maybe well
they have i i've tried um
using they have sea soaps i mean sea
sponges
you know it's really rough
the loofah too hard on your face
but my my but some people would i'm a
delicate flower
some people would say that the washcloth
is no no no they've got hey you could
you can go to the store and get some
kind of like a baby washcloth if your
skin's real sensitive maybe watch cloud
now we're cooking i use pumice i find
that works very well
all right in toilets so there's my mom's
uh beauty uh routine yep
yep the washcloth should have been
better
well it reminds me of like i was gonna
say one punch man he's like the
strongest person that ever lived and
they go how did you get so strong and he
goes i do 100 push-ups every day
it's not that many exactly
he's just born with incredible strength
and you're born with incredible beauty
that's very sweet
you're welcome mom and doesn't he look
more like me than gary now that you've
seen a camera on gary
everyone keeps on on saying that you and
i don't look like each other although
you have dad's shaped face
but you've got my eyes i don't ever
thought i looked like either of you guys
in my i've always suspected that i'm
adopted you've got my teeth see your
teeth are shaped just like mine
i think i'm adopted we will neither
confirm i saw you being born okay yeah
well i wasn't there yeah yes you were
i don't remember it
people there's been lots of discussions
about possibly changing your curtain
yeah we've been thinking about that do
you have any thoughts on what kind of
custom curtain you would like well
um red is my favorite color
black and red
i don't know that's very dramatic but i
think maybe i like that black and red
you think it's going to be too dark does
black and red have a stigma like isn't
that kind of like uh an evil color
scheme or something
i mean it sounds right i i don't know it
depends on what red a nazi
the blood red with the black is maybe a
little nazi yeah it's a little nazi-ish
but it doesn't have to be blood red but
we're taking it back we're taking it
back you should have a contrast i mean
you could do i don't know
is you want like red red
no i no i don't want
red i'm just saying word's my favorite
color dude let's go blood red let's go
not we're taking a full nazi germany
we're taking back nazi germany how about
white
white and black
yeah
no a little little what are you an angel
tone it down
i was gonna say with the red and the
black you could have a graphic something
like jews will not replace us oh
good idea just cover all bases there
that's a good idea any other like maybe
uh
maybe any other anti-semitic slogans you
know you can add you like purple purple
is your favorite what ela was thinking
which is something nice you might like
is she was thinking to do some original
art on a white coat oh that would be
pretty with lots of red in it maybe lots
of red that would work yeah okay good
unless it would would it clash with with
with what i wear
are we better with solid yeah probably
that's what i was thinking is a solid
let's go blood red let's just get
[ __ ] weird with it dude let's just
like yeah dude people gonna tune in and
be like whoa this is crazy
red
we'll have to uh either replace the
table or paint the table yeah we'll
paint the table you know when i was a
little girl
one of my favorite movies was the
unsinkable molly brown and i remember in
the in the movie the whole movie
everything in her house the furniture
was all
like red
like really red and then my mother
surprised me and she bought
she she she uh reupholstered a love seat
and put it in my chair it was red
and then i had one of those canopy beds
and it was all white so my whole room
was white and red
until i think about molly brown there
yeah i'm all
over understanding that's the
that was pretty unsinkable well she's
not the only one that survived titanic
why she got a whole movie and stuff
um
she was well because she floats i mean
that's not that much of an achievement i
don't know she was she was very rich in
a book and there had been a whole bunch
of other things that she admitted but
she's famous for floating i mean uh
let's be honest no i think i think she
was hey she did political or something
like that i'd have to google jack didn't
make it no he didn't bro
yeah douche loser
loser all right so anyway let's throw it
to a commercial when we come back
we are going to be
get i can't wait to hear you guys
explain the creep show drama oh my god
and then we'll be doing that three pages
three pages of next hey we got a whole
book report you're back in school i i
felt like yeah
all right we'll be right back after a
word from our sponsors
credit karma has always been there to
help you make better financial decisions
and now they want to help even more with
credit karma money spend account you're
going to be rewarded for good money
habits credit card money is a brand new
checking account where you can win cash
reimbursements for making purchases and
when you use your credit karma money
debit card you can win daily instant
karma purchase reimbursements on items
up to five thousand dollars said what
just pay for your debit card and just
pay with your debit card and if you win
you'll be notified on the spot and your
instant karma cash will be added right
back to your spend account credit karma
money has already given away over three
million dollars in instant karma to over
50 000 credit karma members and counting
open your fdic insurance spend account
for free there's no minimum balance
requirements there's no overdraft fees
and free withdrawals from a network of
over 50 000 atms people and between july
1st and july 23rd
when you make a purchase between july
1st and july 23 you'll be automatically
entered to win
one million dollars
credit karma money progress starts here
right now visit
creditkarma.com win money to open your
free account and start winning instant
karma go to creditkarma.com win money to
sign up for free and start winning
instant karma that's
creditkarma.com slash win money insta
karma is sponsored by credit card no
purchase necessary exclusion the term
supplies your rules banking service
provided by mvb bank incorporated
members fdic maxima balance of transfer
limit supply
fat guy like me let's be honest i'm
always trying to cut down on carbs sugar
and unhealthy foods and basically when
you're doing that you come to realize
cereal doesn't fit that equation
until now
sorry but it's that exciting magic spoon
is the
cereal breakthrough that has changed my
life and soon you're zero grams of sugar
13 to 14 grams of protein and only four
net grams of carbs in each serving wow
yeah and only 140 calories per serving
it's keto friendly gluten free oh brain
free soy free and low carb unfortunately
it's literally made out of like milk
oh
for you but great for you know if you're
not like those in dollar
variety pack
comes with cocoa fruity frosted and
peanut butter they're all amazing i
personally love the cocoa you know the
chocolate
the peanut butter that sounds good
the peanut butter is good it's
interesting flavor it's like salty which
i like it's like a salty sweet
but the coconut or the uh the cocoa
chocolate is amazing the fruity tastes
just like that beaut the fruity and the
frost is like that childhood perfect
cereal it's so good it tastes amazing
um
it tastes just like the child my
childhood and it's but it's super
nutritious no sugar i mean it's freaking
amazing go to magicspoon.com families
and grab a variety pack and try today
and be sure to use our promo code
families at checkout to save five
dollars off your order
nice magic spoon is so confident in
their product it's backed with 100
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason they'll refund your
money no questions asked remember get
your next delicious bowl of glue of
guilt-free cereal at magicspoon.com
families and use code families to save
five dollars thank you magic spoon for
sponsors i truly do love their cereal so
much
once upon a time in a tiny apartment in
southern california two callers dropped
out teamed up to create a watch company
that broke all the rules fair prices
unexpected colors clean original designs
it was the movement mvmt grew into one
of the fastest growing watch brands
shipping to over 160 countries around
the globe now movement has expanded into
blue light glasses to protect your eyes
from screens minimalist jewelry and more
style essentials that don't break the
bank all designed out of the california
headquarters
um
listen we've actually uh we've been
working with movement and i love it it's
like you usually get this kind of
quality from like a four or five hundred
dollar department store like these
really big name brands same quality for
a fraction of the price
uh because they're all online and they
control the process from start to finish
so it's like nice you don't need to pay
as some guy in italy who's making the
same [ __ ] it's all a bunch of [ __ ]
it's the movement
you know
okay and they have a bunch of really
cool styles i definitely recommend just
going to the website and checking out
all the really beautiful styles mvmt.com
families they've got blue light glasses
you know i myself spent a lot of day a
lot of time in front of the computer a
lot
and they've got these ever squirrel bru
blue light filtering glasses that
protect your eye from strain
and poor sleeping patterns and they look
fantastic too it's got it all it's the
movement mom
if you want to elevate your look and
style and not break the bank go join the
movement and get 15 off today with free
shipping and free returns by going to
mvmt.com families again that's mvmt.com
families
thank you to bright sellers if you are a
wine drinker or not but the thing is
picking a wine can be very intimidating
it can be very difficult and it can be
frustrating that's why bright cellars
has this beautiful service let me tell
you about it mom they use a wine
algorithm to match you with wines you
are guaranteed to love all you have to
do is take their 30 second quiz and they
match you with wines based on things you
know you like
for example chalk you say do you like
chocolate yes what's your favorite type
of juice apple and then they crush the
numbers they biohack your literal body
to send up perfect wine that just fits
into your taste buds like a piece of
gestures pieces
fantastic that sounds good
ah bruh so dan you tried bro you tried
it i mean i'm not drinking that much
these days because you know he was
pregnant and i'm on like uh you know
lexapro you're not supposed to drink on
that so dan took the lead on this one
tell me about you yes i was happy to
take the lead yeah it was cool yeah like
ethan said you fill out a little uh
survey it only takes a couple minutes
you give it kind of an idea of your
taste and they send you a bunch of stuff
they sent me uh i think it was six
bottles of red six bottles let's go yeah
i haven't gotten through all six yet and
i'm taking it i'm taking my time taking
my time yeah but yeah uh yeah they sent
a couple merlots a couple cabs a couple
of these uh tempranillo says it's sent
it sends wines from all over the world
yeah you have not tried it was a spanish
wine it was a type that i had never
heard of before but is good so uh yeah i
was impressed
you know they also say that each box
comes with an education card so you can
learn about the wine as you're tasting
it know the right serving temperature
what food to pair with it it's a
beautiful perfect for a day tonight or
just if you're lush and you need to
spice it up nah yeah that's a good idea
um you can also switch up the amount of
reds whites and roses
if you're a seasonal wine drinker you
can skip and order whenever you want the
best part is if you don't like a bottle
of wine bright cellars offers a delight
guarantee ooh
i've never been guaranteed a delight
before we'll send you a replacement
bottle in your next order so for a
limited time families listeners get 50
off their first box of six bottles wow
damn bright sellers by going to
brightsellers.com families at
thebrightsellers.com families that's
bright sellers b-r-i-g-h-t-c-e-l-l-a-r-s
com backslash families to receive 50 off
your first six bottle order bright
sellers helping families discover wine
to love
and us families yeah i families
okay creep show art
who is creep show art
uh it's a it's
a girl by the name of shannon okay yeah
so you want me just to well so let me
let me set it up so creativity show art
i heard about this drama i didn't know
much about this channel apparently she's
like a drama
gossip t-channel slash art channel
she made one the only time i knew about
her she made one really nasty video
about me and trisha
really where she said that like
we had plant it was just super bizarre
because she like made this claim like it
was factual without any evidence she
goes ethan and trisha are faking the
drama and the relationship with moses
isn't real
and i know this and and they go eat and
the title of the video is like h3h3 has
fallen so far
and it was about how me and trisha are
faking everything and i was like girl
this [ __ ] is real or as real as it gets
and i just found it i thought it was so
nasty because it was just like totally
fabricated
so that was my whole thing but
apparently a lot of people in the
community liked her a lot before
all this kind of drama came to light the
one thing i do want to point out about
the
creep show art which i'll put on the
screen
is that she suffered as far as i
understand it the greatest percentage
lost of subscribers of any cancellation
ever did you know that i i was yeah i
learned that last night so
wow mama oh really so i will say she's
she had at the
she had uh where did she start she
started at like 600 000 or something
and she's down this is unbelievable
she's down now to 350. so you're looking
at almost 50 percent sub loss that is
never
that has never been seen before in
youtube history i mean it is a a faint a
fantastic
well you know when i was yeah i was uh
you know i had to learn about it you
told me to do my homework and so when i
got online to try to learn about what
the whole
deal was
i watched a bunch of uh of different uh
hey guys sorry i was just pulling up her
channel to
hey guys
what the heck sorry that was her i was
just trying to pull up her channel to
show up as good go ahead mom i'm sorry
well i was just what you know i was
trying to learn and so i was watching
different podcasts and different you
know people putting out information and
i couldn't i found one
piece of hers like all of it had
disappeared interesting i couldn't even
watch any of her videos but just one i
see a lot here i don't think she erased
that much
well i don't know
fantastic last night i couldn't find
yeah i heard that she did she has erased
a lot of the videos maybe that that you
heard about
um but but anyway so so what so tell me
this girl's shannon so what what is the
drama tell me what happened okay
first of all
the greatest cancellation in youtube
history
the most thorough
right well deserved
well okay
i have to to tell you about shannon i i
almost have to tell you
about money
no the bad
the back story yeah which is regarding a
girl by the name of emily okay
and emily's um
this it's so weird how this whole weird
dynamic ties in together interesting
okay so this young girl
emily
from the age of 14 years old she has
been an addict okay heroin
sleeping pills i don't know how at 14
years old you you that's rough
yeah i mean it was awful anyways and
this young lady
was you know a musician i mean she was a
singer
and uh it all started when she met this
guy
okay
he became her boyfriend
and his name was anthony parker and i
can say that because she says that on
her own video anthony parker right i
don't have to say allegedly this is her
boyfriend this is this you know her
ex-boyfriend this is her ex-boyfriend
right and she met him at a place called
uh
it was called nichols something nichols
wait let me see oh we need the name of
the place where they met okay
well
nickelback nickel city they met at a
place it was like a musical city i think
it was like a bowling alley or something
i don't know
it was just it was just a little tiny
nothing okay so so and people meet at
nickel city and they perform
they perform together
well she didn't perform with him because
that's how they met he was performing
and that's how that's how they met okay
and so um
oh god anyways this guy turns out this
this uh anthony of young love
young love and he is a svengali a
what he's like a svengali what is this
fangalli it's somewhat i got a little
piece of fuzz on my face
um a svengali is someone who's very
controlling and tells you what to do how
to do
you know i mean he just like tells her
what to do how to dress wait what do you
think is it sven
it's it's like an archetype uh of a
character oh i didn't know about this
here it says fengouli is that just a
halloween thing no yeah that's a guy
that hosts bad movies right oh sven
ghoulie okay
okay wait i'm trying to define this
clock define sven
[Music]
there's a wikipedia page for it oh there
it
is
a l i okay sven golly svengali not to be
confused with sven ghoulie yeah yeah
yeah that's a
show host a person who exercised a
controlling or mesmeric influence on
another especially for a sinister
purpose
wow what a fantastic use of the word
svengali well
actually that he fits the bill i just
learned what a sphinx
suspension
is
svengali anyways so i mean it turns out
they they perform together she sang with
him
and uh
all along she is into drugs and she
just tells
emily tells the story on her channel
that she used to
i mean she's young you know she's at
this time when she's performing she's
around 17 she said she used to she lived
with her parents and she used to leave
her window open and that's how people
would get in and out well under the
influence of heroin she was really
drugged out this anthony guy crawled in
her window and
her basically
you know he just had his way with
her what
our word oh oh oh oh oh oh i forgot i
forgot it's okay we'll we'll bleep it
okay so sorry sorry just to learning the
internet ways okay
so this book were they dating like what
was that yeah they were they were dating
but i mean she was under the influence
okay so she was there like
she was knocked out in her bed
crawled in
did his thing and
and so she remembers bits and pieces
okay you know so that's how she knows
what happened okay so
let's fast forward through their
relationship let's
okay
and dad you're not happy with the
retelling of uh emily and ferguson
bengali
i i think we should move on with the
main theme which is
it's a dad you can't rush the creep show
art drama okay i stand corrected
maybe not you know what that sounds like
my father get to the chase
get to the chase he hated all the in
between okay so we need a proper setup
i'm here i'm i'm i'm i'm your dude i did
all this research you're doing great i
love it
anyway
so
basically she doesn't like the way she
is with him
she has a therapist this is a few years
later
no this is at the at you know 17 18
years old the therapist says to her
you know
ditch this guy and the way you can do it
is get angry
so she tells her
to get angry that's what she tells her
viewers seems like i mean allegedly
that's what she said so she said that
she became a raging [ __ ]
she said that she became an
anti-feminist and she she picked on
celebrities and she sang
um
oh oh oh right she basically she became
not a nice person i guess she would get
on on
the other
therapist on the advice of her there
talking about emily still emily right
right right so basically
uh
this shannon
girl now we're talking about creep show
art creep show art
okay she wasn't creep show art at the
time she was also a musician all these
people are so talented they're artists
they're musicians it's really strange
anyway
this media has a habit of do you wish
they did something more productive with
their lives mom
with all these talents that they have
it's such a waste of life right well
not this you know
there's always going to be someone
better than you
as good as you think you are there's
always going to be someone better than
you okay and so you know this is a way
for them to express their art on these
videos and they become celebrities and
they make a living okay so they're all
so that's okay they're all youtubers
yeah okay yeah yeah yeah okay
air quote talent
that my dad is okay
on the musician part right well she's no
mariah carey all right let's
so whatever anyway so this is good my
dad's giving adults he's just he's he's
yeah he's annotating you're reconnecting
out to page six so shannon who is who's
not creep show art yet
meets anthony
at their work sven golly mr svengali at
work
they become um
i i guess uh uh an item because emily
you know she breaks up with him
because he's not good for her and she's
mad
he's mad he's a weirdo he's just wait
who's mad i thought emily was mad why
would emily be mad she broke up with him
didn't hers no emily's happy to still
get rid of this
barnacle didn't her therapist tell her
to be mad oh she's mad but she also
broke up that's how she was able to you
know it's kind of like a teenager you
have fights with your parents and it's a
way of breaking away she broke up with
them you know it's good for her yeah
okay so so shannon meets anthony yeah
and they become an item anyways they're
both musicians
he she sings on one of his tracks and
for some reason he's still sending
messages to emily they're kind of in a
weird
transition yeah
i don't know she should have just cut
him off loose completely but anyway
so he sends her the track and she
because she's being in this mean mode
emily
she said that she
said that shannon was not a good uh
she didn't do a good job on the trip
you know
that he should
let her sing on his track emily emily
came for shannon right wow so she was
not nice
to shannon okay with her singing the
makings of a super villain yeah
so
this is emily that's not shannon but
emily is seen from in the incredibles
when
he tries to take a picture with mr
incredible and he's like not now kid and
i became a super villain right
kind of like that
so
i guess
anthony decides to use
emily's vocals
shannon gets upset oh a double cross
right and so emily don't forget this
guy's a svengali he's all about him i
didn't forget okay so
he
he uses
shannon he uses emily's vocals shannon
gets pissed finds out about all this
wicked stuff and finds out that her
boyfriend her present boyfriend who is
in communication with his ex-girlfriend
emily emily and sven you know so shannon
is dating this guy
it's the one guy between the two of them
but just to clarify shannon is dating
this guy
anthony and but the anthony betrayed
shannon by using emily's vocals correct
burn of the [ __ ] decade correct
right
so basically
that's the back story okay so there's
beef there's bitter there's better b
right but okay so now
on on shannon's side
i can imagine shannon is like you know
what this rotten dude she's dating and
then also he's using his ex-girlfriend's
vocals not a nice situation right for
shannon not no no actually it wasn't a
nice situation for shannon
however
you know people change and emily
through therapy
hopefully a different therapist than the
one that told her to stay mad at
everything well she through you know
through growth and you know
she explains you know you're not a
different person you just evolve and you
you know you want to
make things better
and so she starts on her channel um her
youtube channel
i think it's youtube
um
this this thing called sketchbook story
time okay she started a youtube channel
she starts a youtube channel okay and
she is actually a really good artist she
doodles and she draws quotes on the good
artist or do you allow that
uh
no comment
no you have no insight okay he he can't
draw a straight line okay i just wasn't
sure because you were out here with the
air quotes doesn't mean i can't be a
critic yeah well yeah you that's true
you are a critic anyway so
so she draws and she talks over her
drawing
or she draws over her speaking whichever
way you want to look at it
and so this is her format she
she and it's you know she's grown her
channel
and so
in comes the the the shannon and this
ex-boyfriend of hers who is now
shannon's boyfriend
anthony parks i don't know if they're
married now but
i know that they're together
and
uh
she starts a channel
fascinating and she calls it the same
thing
sketch book story time same exact title
she kind of
rips off emily's same exact name that's
pretty much what i and how much time has
passed
since this drama with the vocals
probably um a couple of years okay so
everyone's gone their separate ways
everyone's gone their separate ways and
so
now
shannon knows who emily is because she
ditched of course dissed her stuff
emily
didn't really know it was shannon she
just knows that it was a girl singing so
emily doesn't really know who shannon is
but shannon knows who emily is got it
okay
so uh
it's the same sort of format page are we
on by the way oh i don't know it's uh
it's all messed up i can't even read my
own notes
i don't know it's rotating
anyway so um
basically
uh
people are calling out on to to emily
that that this creep show art is
stealing her work and then she wasn't
creep show art at the time no
right she was sketchbook art aware of
the same right right but there you go
there's another channel well but but um
emily reaches out to shannon not knowing
who she is and says
i appreciate your artwork you're a good
artist yada yada but can you change your
name
and shannon replies to her you know
thank you for bringing it to my
attention even though she knows what's
going on because she purposefully did
this
you know thanks for bringing it to my
attention there are there are other
artists out there using the same
you know sketchbook art
uh titles or things like that confusing
so she no but she says i'll change my
name so she changes it to creep show art
okay okay so the hence creepshow art
and then basically it's back and forth
with um
with like creep show art has stolen
other people's artwork
so because as i understand it on this on
her videos she's drawing as she's
talking about something correct so how
does she steal someone's art well she
can go to someone else's website steal
their art and then just sort of draw
over it and embellish it okay sure so
she's she's been doing that kind of
stuff and uh let me see that's frowned
upon yeah yeah you don't want to steal
other people's uh
stuff and then they start then it gets
it starts to get really it really goes
south where um
uh shannon and this guy anthony
kind of make her feel like she's friends
with them
i guess there's different
websites uh let me see what are these
things they're like sock puck puppets
sock puppets anyone
sock puppets are it's a
sock puppet account is usually right
you're saying they have a fake account
right they're fictitious online uh okay
yeah go ahead and define that i like
that okay it's a fictitious online
identity to block
someone or create false uh majority
opinion love that you know so they're
creating fake accounts yeah they need to
pretend like they're her friend right
they don't know who she is it's vote
stacking i mean they do that
they do that they do that in politics
too
you know i think mom's burying the
burying the lead a little bit here
because most of this came from
a another uh
discussion site low low or low motion no
no no no no it's called it's called are
we talking
and that's the website it's a gossip
thread
okay okay so let me clarify
now we're on the low cow everyone's
confused which is a gossip website right
so shannon and her husband
right they have made fake accounts right
and then they get on this gossip thread
yeah and they make it sound like emily's
they start talking about emily but why
do you say that they're friends are they
friends well what this what this creep
show does and she's done this to other
people she's befriended people where
they actually think like
you and another youtuber might be
friends whether you meet meanwhile
physically
right and she pretends and so they so
they think oh it's there's no way it's
this person right you know they're
trying to figure out who's stalking me
and who's doing this because this girl
shannon
set up a fake identity like she was a
young person and she was stalking
emily they even they even took pictures
of like her her uh neighbor
like where she lives oh and then and she
thought that they were like gonna come
and kill her oh so they would take
photos of like her house and her
neighborhood well not her house but like
in her area they would go they posted on
local and what would they say well they
were like you know they're trying to
scare her they were they were scaring
her with the things that they were
saying psycho
right right and she's trying to figure
out i guess because there's ways to
figure out
the identity of whose these sock pocket
puppets are because they tend to
come out at the same time or there's
there's like it's kind of like a
fingerprint even though you might not
have an actual name they can figure it
out like 98 of the time when they really
investigate it
well the administrator yeah i think man
i think it's that's what outed them the
ad the ip well before we get so what did
they do
what's an ip
okay an ip is the internet protocol we
have that if we have ip defined on her
cheat sheet
it's it's a set of rules that dictate
how data should be delivered over the
public network dude i can't believe you
wrote that down
i did
and i was running back
and there's also a tcp
which is an assistant
commissioner of police
also known as indian police server
service
tcp
it's also defined tcp again
tcp is an assistant commissioner of
police
what
that's what it says i think what you're
thinking of is the tcp ip
right yes that's exactly what then read
again how you defined it
read the definition it's a commission
it's like a police patrol for the for
for the commissioner maybe policing
would be a better place okay police okay
policing policy no no
no it's there's no policing commission
it's just it's i think they're look it
up look up tcp i think it's left yeah
literally i think that acronym is likely
used in uh multiple contexts and you you
may have looked up the wrong definition
the wrong thing
it's just it's a technical term there's
no police body of the internet okay well
policing what's supposed on low count
just for clarity so shannon even had
accounts that she would create to
criticize herself right to to build
sympathy for her and she was plotting
against this right and that's pretty a
violation even of this sketchy
discussion site's rules so the admins
outed her right so there's actual
youtubers may i ask what more did she do
what did she do like whole the whole
suite of harassments shannon did to
emily
well
she just um
she just said terrible terrible things
and this guy anthony
whom emily said she knew that all of his
his buddies and they would go to high
school and talk about how they would
shoot up
they were the school you know like this
whole columbine deal they were saying
she wanted to shoot up a school
anthony so she knew what kind of
character was so when she figured
anthony was saying he wanted to shoot up
a school yeah oh this guy's a school
shooter no he he never did but he talked
they talked about it yeah he did stuff
like that
um let's see let me see where my ah
there's so much don't take your time let
me oh my god and then she even oh and
then wait wait wait so that also there's
a photo bucket storage
site
okay that you can get personal photos
which they did of emily because emily i
guess posed for pictures when she was
um a minor
also
uh well she didn't say new but she said
she posed for she imply
she said she took okay so what happened
with the with the pics well you know you
can sh these these photo bucket sites
you can you can share these images
and and she actually when she was trying
to get her life together before she
actually
was on youtube she got a job and they
sent
they sent photos to her boss and got her
fired wow so you know that she they're
really really messing with her life they
were making her life they were trying to
ruin her life they took private photos
they got her fired they were threatening
her showing pictures of her neighborhood
on locale right and also also
they accused her of
uh like pre-op like like she like
transgender type of
insults
right like she was they were saying
things like oh do you still have your
man parts
and stuff like that now this woman has
two children emily but they were he was
he was accusing her of not being a
different account so it looked like
right it wasn't them criticizing her it
was all
right on locale they were shredding a
rumor that she was trans right
right even doxed her own sister
something came up where she had released
this information and lied about her
sister
and that was part of the admins getting
rid of her shannon's box her own sister
yeah so why her sister joined emily but
there were quite a few people that made
it oh it's crazy about this
that
talked about
they were her friends and it seems like
she just put so much planning she
you know lex luthor where superman says
if you only used your genius for the
good instead of evil
if they took half of the time they spent
plotting
to mess with people
and you know i said this last week too
and do something good do something
creative do something to help humanity
instead of tearing it down they could be
the world would be a little better place
yeah no they got into her facebook
account facebook
emily's facebook got into emily's yes
they said that they were
they said that they were friends and
that somehow their accounts were
compromised and so they wanted another
friend request so emily you know
naively gave them you know accepted them
as friends and so they got into her and
they blocked her out of facebook and at
the time she said it was impossible to
get back in
and uh spend so much time oh my god and
and the thing is that that's what
they're i don't know it was terrible
because
shannon felt like her boyfriend was had
cheated on her with the ex emily and she
said
right that's what allegedly allegedly
but it's it's just it's
it's
it's wild how two years later these two
people are so still obsessed
with this girl who's minding her own
business and probably hasn't thought
about them she just wants to get on with
her life but the thing is with with this
this creep show they've befriended other
people like other people will send a
message to them and say hey i really
like you whatever they'll pretend to be
their friend and then
these puppet
things the sock puppets
accounts and then they say all these
terrible things about whoever
you know paid them the compliment and so
then how was she finally
how did people figure out about all the
stuff she's done yeah what was the
catalyst for her losing all of these
subscribers emily figured it out because
because on one of the videos that
shannon
put out on her creep show she did a
sketch of anthon of anthony
and and emily she never even knew that
they were together she didn't put the
connection together she had no idea
that shannon was behind this or anthony
so when she didn't know who creepshow
was she just thought she was uh
just a faceless
right because because she never showed
her face
she thought it was another fellow artist
she had no idea who was sending her and
and destroying her life emily saw
that shannon did a drawing of her ex
right and then was like oh she goes oh
my god and she put all the pieces
together been harassing me yep doxxing
me getting me fired right taking
pictures of my neighborhood right right
and she even was concerned at one point
for shannon's well-being because she
knew anthony was this
evil svengali
and
it turns out that shannon's just as bad
as anthony sounds like it yeah they may
be their perfect love match
well i don't know but who loves this you
know it's a love story in a way
but
wait wait so but like that's not proof
right though so how did they prove that
all these posts
from these soft puppets she says she's
got receipts i'm not really quite you're
missing a detail here which is that the
admins on the website
her she went to police she went to a
private detective
who else did she go to wait hold on
you're missing well they told her to
take snapshots
of all the stuff that was posted
the police
her attorneys told her this
the police told her she didn't have a
case that there was no way to prove it
yeah i mean
and so her attorney said take snapshots
of everything and i guess through the
snapshots it shows
you're mis you are missing the detail is
that
when shannon or when yeah when shannon
was posting all these terrible things on
locale
she was promoting her own channel and
the admins knew it was her based on the
ip and everything
and um i don't think she was promoting
her own channel as much as she was just
trying to destroy emily that's not
against the rules of low cow what's
against the rules is promoting your own
thing i think that's where she went awry
and the admins were just the admins did
a big expose where they're like yo just
so you know this person posting all
these horrible comments right is
actually creep show art and the admins
of local
dumped on her am i correct in that can
anyone back me up that's correct i think
that is what happened the only detail is
it wasn't by ip it was actually by uh
just browser cookies i think so it
wasn't it was not ip it was not ip
that's an important detail because of
how she tried to defend herself which
i'm assuming is coming up so wait so so
what does it mean that they figured it
out well browser cookies according okay
according to everything that i've been
watching
this is so oh my god this is just so
crazy it's so crazy
when a youtuber puts out information no
matter what he puts it under his name
you know i guess there's a there's a
familiarity of how they do things it's
almost like um like jack the ripper he
always killed his his his victims a
certain way some things are just like
it's a a a signature type of a thing
does that make sense no
well go on i'm curious where you're
going with this well they figured it out
based on her signature well you know
it's like no that's not how they figured
out dan what does it mean to well as i
understand it they actually have it
wasn't like a forensic like oh she wrote
this like
shannon which i think is what you mean
they put it out at the same time these
accounts were all
created at the same time okay so there
was the harassing happened at the same
time plus emily pointed out the fact
that that she was constantly
being um
like no other youtuber would ever
compare
her work with another youtubers like
like shannon said when she wrote to
emily
you know that she that i i'm not copying
you that there were other youtubers that
did this format and yada yada now they
do but at the time they didn't and so
a lot of other people were writing to
emily saying did you know that you and
and creep show art have like the same
drawings have the same this
so there was always comparison between
her and that particular
so dan how do they figure out via
cookies what does that mean well it just
means she wasn't very careful and you
know she's logging into a bunch of
different accounts from the same
computer same browser and the
administrators of the site um you know
once they
caught on to it they could investigate
and they could see that and so they
could literally see that she's logged
into her youtube channel
there's no room for doubt like they're
like this is definitely right
yes all kinds of information about your
browsing online is stored in in
something called cookies on your browser
right the admins are like this is 100
creep show art well you can see that
she's logged into it they said that they
can check it like it it's it's like 98
proof okay type of a deal right and so
then what how does how does a creep show
up oh this is another thing that i've
left out which i think is kind of an
important thing okay
anthony
i can i'm losing you i know it's no i'm
not i'm not you're not okay and
i i'm tired because theodore woke up but
he was up like all night it's just it's
a whole thing no i'm i'm okay i'm
calculated i'm captivated
i'm sorry for yawning it's not perfect
everyone's going come on down no no no
no
sorry already no i'm with anthony and
shannon decided
they planned this that they wanted to
become homeless
right
yeah this is another weird schtick
they decided they were going to live out
of their car for a year to save money
for real
yeah
yeah
okay that's what they things are tight
then sure why not i guess well you know
and so one of the things that creep show
art kept on saying you know stop picking
on me i was homeless i have all these
issues and and um oh that was another
thing um
that that they kept on shannon kept on
picking on emily
because of not only of her drug habit
but she had an eating disorder
and and so every anything that emily had
shannon was saying i have okay
you know and so she and then she was
saying oh i'm i'm homeless and you know
please don't rag on me because but so
when it came out that local was like
this is 100
shannon how did she defend herself
shannon
um she just
well like i said i couldn't find a lot
of her her videos because dan i know you
you you
yeah when i looked it over she
the key thing was she made a uh
community post on her youtube channel
okay see youtube show
yeah she just gave us that homework
assignment like hey no no hey come on
this is a tangled mess this is a tangled
mask
help me dan help me mr wizard yeah
a deep cut to find anyways um yeah here
is the community post um i guess i'll
send it to you ethan if you want to pull
it yeah put it on or yeah just throw it
up on discord or something yeah i got
you okay so here this is weird she
posted her explanation on her community
tab on youtube which is like the last
place i would want to post something if
i wanted anyone to see it right um
although it has does have 9 000 likes so
i guess a lot of people did see it
but the the key part is that she said
someone was posing has her
on certain sites
spoofing her ip doxing her family
members and writing about herself
sending death threats to other people
from her account making false accounts
to spam her comment section
uh spam her friends with hateful things
so according to her over the course of
years
ten years the the highest level this
incredible hacker who was able to spoof
her id
and log into lol
clow and can even convince the admins
it's her while simultaneously sending
hate and death threats and trying to
really it wasn't me it was this weird
stuff she was actually gas lighting
oh is that a gas lighting that's what
gaslighting is i think it's just
straight up lying nope when you make
when someone does something to you and
you make them
think
i feel like we're all no no no no no no
no that is gaslighting okay weird she's
a famous movie from the uh basically
it's called gaslight it's a very uh
popular term right now well people are
misusing it okay constantly and
gaslighting is like i mean
it's when you confuse someone of their
objective reality exactly exactly and
she was making it sound like emily was
doing this to her when reality it was
completely the other way around oh she
was trying to say well actually it's
emily who did to me yeah that is right
okay so
basically the admins of local responded
like dude we we got your cookies there's
no question about it like stop lying and
that was slam dunk
creep show art is definitely not living
in our car
yeah not by choice
yeah
yeah i you know
the whole thing is really crazy
i mean
this whole media
or medium
of youtube
yeah it's like it attracts
so many
mis
i know i i i it's it's it's like it's
like
a moth to light i know it you know i
mean there's there's a lot of strange
issues
people have oh man there's so much bad
activity on the internet and on youtube
there's so many bad actors it's it's
crazy yeah yeah but i do want the whole
story yes but i do want to give a shout
out to someone okay we love mom's shout
outs i want to shout out to a girl i
hope i'm pronouncing your name right
chaos brown
and she's a youtuber and she went ahead
and she explained the whole drama
if you want to watch her channel he
probably did a much better job than i
did yeah hard to believe
oh [ __ ] tails brown my mother brown and
one thing that touched my heart about
this young girl
kells brown or emily no kale's brown
okay
she
shared
something about her herself her life
when she was a young girl her mom and
dad were in a financial
situation not a good one i guess when
when there was a whole
what was it the um
i don't know the economy was was going
crazy
not in a good way and
inflation and anyways her family was you
might want to say couch
surfing for a year
like she wasn't out on the streets or
anything but she was basically homeless
and as a young child it left quite an
impression on her and um so when when uh
creepshow made a comment and start
boohooing about the fact that she was
homeless when it was by choice
you know she's saying you can't
use this an is as an excuse like because
she took a personal right because you
know this was by choice where this young
girl she knows what it's like to be
homeless and she never uses it as a
weapon like oh don't listen to me or or
don't dis me because i i was homeless
you know she picked herself up by your
bootstraps and and look at now she's on
youtube and she was
very clever and articulate and so shout
out to uh okay kale is brown kale's
brown good for you
well that's that's it i mean that's the
creep show art i think that was you did
a pretty good job oh my yeah i had the
worst migraine i gotta tell you i had a
hard time unraveling that myself but i
think
i think is
is how does she rate their of youtube
villains in your mind shannon
you know
that's interesting because
i'd have to say that this anthony parker
is the puppeteer i think he's the
ultimate she's bad she's really bad
because if you watch her videos some of
the ways that she talks this guy should
be she's just not she's not good but you
know what she went right along with them
and so
you know i'd say she's up there i say
she might be i mean i can't i don't have
all the information about other
youtubers but right yeah
she's bad she's bad news okay
creep show art well thank you mom and
dad for illuminating us creep show art
exploded by my parents i'm exhausted yes
dad uh
is there anyone doing good things on
youtube that maybe we could before yes
it's not like that we always think about
people don't over overdo it no we we
refer to you as the batman i don't like
that you don't i appreciate it but it's
like i think you're overestimating what
i do here
well i'm your mother you have tremendous
power you're my oh i forgot that that
reminds me my dad is is drunk with power
on twitter
you're welcome
my dad i'm hanging out the house
for 4th of july and my dad goes i have 3
800 followers and now i understand the
power you yield
and i just thought it was so funny that
3 000 twitter followers have gone
straight to my dad's head he's consumed
by his power and influence right yeah
but tell tell gary tell him why totally
power hungry it's all part of my plan
for world domination you're about to
start posting on lol cow about me
no
like pinky in the brain that you know
we're all
fairly insignificant in terms of the the
world at large and
when i was a kid
way back when
you know i i probably wouldn't have met
3
800 people in my entire life
and now i can communicate with these
people and and the only
issue i was saying is that it can be
used for good there was a
a petition going around from someone
that got sent to me to support the uh
woman
olympic athlete on the u.s team
that was suspended from the olympics for
uh testing positive for marijuana
and it was really horrible to her she
just found out her mother had died from
the media and didn't want to drink so
she just you know had a little marijuana
i think she had even already completed
her event
and she got tested and now she can't go
to the olympics and
people think that's unfair it's legal in
the state that she did it in
and
uh the fda considers marijuana a
performance-enhancing drug mm-hmm if you
want to fall asleep
a de-enhancing performance drug or death
it could enhance like taste maybe yeah
exactly but not anything athletic you
know that's why it could enhance uh your
laziness and apathy yeah very
your paranoia anxiety very few knife
fights at concerts where people are
stoned you know there's everyone's just
relaxed no one gets pulled over and gets
a traffic but anyway the point is you
retweeted this petition retweeted and
you are just you go ahead well normally
one person new person might have even
seen it now i would say it got retweeted
70 times maybe just from your single
response my retweet that is
signatures of this petition which
probably pushed it over the top how do
you know you got 50. that seems generous
when i look on my statistics there i
mean you can see you're crunching the
numbers on the weekend
right oh see that's funny that you're in
the analytics crunching numbers because
i've never even done that
well yeah i looked uh
yeah you don't know you're [ __ ] out a
page that showed you know how many my
interactions have uh increased in what
perspective they were multi-column 2 800
which is like
from from ground zero up you know i had
nowhere to go so we're crunching the
numbers you have i think you may have
changed the world i think you might get
her back in the olympics
i hope she gives me the credit i'm so
due if well now i mean if she does i
mean we need to point to gary's retweet
three thousand followers i should
probably get a free trip to the olympics
in tokyo if that turns out to be the
case
i don't think you want to go to that
super spreading event yeah i'm
vaccinated
not against what they're cooking up
anyway let's cut some here what do you
say mom oh yeah okay oh wait before we
go can i show off my sure what you got
uh
you might want to go sorry
check here
i want to show cause it's always cold in
here so i'm wearing my
teddy fruit
original jacket
work it mom work it is that available no
it's not sold out
but it's a lot of good stuff enjoy it
you know flex it this is really cute
people always love what she's wearing
and then want to get it and it's not
available that's okay you got to just be
stay tuned
stay tuned okay we are going now to the
hair cutting segment my mom just found
out we will only have five minutes
there's nothing to perform the haircut
well you're the genius hairdresser you
gotta it's me again
listen nobody wants to watch us do like
a it's like
nobody wants to watch like a real barber
haircut we gotta get in there oh my god
five minutes that's like if you can't
defeat your untrained
son yeah five minutes come on we should
be able to tell you speed hair cut [ __ ]
that's going to be like the worst
haircut well all right
so the bar is pretty low to begin all
right okay we're gonna set up we'll be
right back i feel like my mom's cheating
right now i'm not cheating you're
prepping the mannequin
is mine getting the same treatment as
yours here oh you better give me the
same starting point because mine looks
all hot mine looks all haggard
and yours is all beautifully treated oh
i just combed her hair well give mine
the same treatment we have this five
minutes it's not started yet that's why
you're cheating okay we'll go pick a
comb here's your bottle
okay so we need to start from the same
spot wait stop with the whole measuring
and [ __ ]
you already started i have five minutes
it didn't start yet okay we have to
start from the same time god i asked dan
if i could like am i doing this right
now can i section her hair
i don't know where i start
you keep asking me that i i don't know
what that means
what is sectioning the hair you know
putting is some hair that i don't want
to be cut out of the way you can when
the timer that sounds like part of the
process to me yeah okay but why does
mine look all haggard and yours looks
good because you have to calm just keep
combing just keep coming and get wet and
calm
just like there's something you're not
telling me no it's hey
all right all right are we ready hold on
no i'm not ready because yours looks
like look how beautiful yours looks how
does it look beautiful her hair is wet
okay does mine look the same
well you have to comb it it's up to you
i'm not cutting your glory ahead too
okay here's what this is the kind of
[ __ ] my mom look how good her hair looks
it's all going back and [ __ ] this is a
buzzer if you want to
use a blaster
okay this is this doesn't have wires
that that'd be easier for you to use
dude yours looks so much better look how
good it looks like
all right here let me prep
where's the water
you cheated dude
look at your mannequins it's just water
for goodness sake
it's all part of the process
okay so while we're prepping my
mannequin dan let's show the karen
uh okay so the karen is kind of like a
interesting cut it's kind of it's kind
of like a bowl it's almost like a female
bowl cut in a way
it's a weird it's an interesting dew
isn't it
it's a disconnected haircut
you got to talk into the mic if you want
people to hear you oh where's the mic
it's a disconnected haircut what does
that mean it's disc
it's disconnected what her head i mean
no no but like like
they don't necessarily match like one
piece of hair doesn't necessarily match
with the other it's
separate it's almost like a separate
haircut
okay
so have we got the karen on screen
okay you got it okay is she wet now here
let me calm her to make her pretty so
you can be happy yeah thank you and then
actually i need to see the karen if
somebody can put it up because
i need to know what i'm doing what i'm
cutting
all right
your new profession
okay oh beautiful she's shedding yeah
hey
you guys are going to have to vacuum the
oh my god is the vault do we have the
volume to do a karen haircut mom
yeah
you you you can do that in five minutes
you know you don't have i i'm not gonna
oh yeah show me that one that is so
hideous
that is the moment all right so let's
get a timer going hold on no touching
hands to yourself all right everybody
ready
all right you know what
do can you take that off the screen the
picture and have a picture of us that
way it's a mirror so i can see what i'm
doing yeah that's good
okay wait wait wait wait
there okay okay go ahead whenever you're
ready start that timer all right here we
go we'll start in five four three two
one
go oh my god
so do i say what i'm what are you doing
get out of here so i'm parting her hair
i'm partying you don't have enough time
for all that okay i'm parting her hair
along the parietal ridge
this is like a demo
and i'm going to
get this out of my way because i don't
want to cut it
because this part not a bad deal
honestly yes
oh my god oh my god ethan you are in
trouble right here
well mom you have five minutes like how
much give us a timer update
uh we're about 40 seconds in oh okay so
fair amount of time i think it looks
something like this
where it's a little shorter here can i
see the karen again
oh you're so funny
i think we need to see some scalp if
that's possible do we have buzzer do we
have a buzzer
oh yes it's the buzzer there okay
fantastic a buzzer buzzer buzzer
clippers good
oh oh oh i thought you meant like okay
oh yeah this is looking this is good i
think
oh it's wait is the battery dead or is
it too intense for it it could be too
intense
i think the battery's dead mom no i i
charged it overnight you're supposed to
use a clunk of hair you just need small
pieces for i thought i could just go for
it with this thing well
here you want to trace it it seems dead
oh i need that that's like that's like
the hair you had in here oh my oh god
i can't believe you just said that
oh lord
okay
[Music]
so here's where we're looking that's
pretty caring right
i mean right there's something to that
oh lord or maybe it's too trendy
currently do we like this this little
thing here or no
mom you're putting in clips you are in
trouble
okay
and then i think it's something like
here we're gonna trim this real short
you guys want to see what's doing yeah
we could see it that's good
yeah this looks great oh my god
what are you doing to that poor head
i don't know how i'm going to do this in
fact give us a time update here
uh
we're uh
let's see about three minutes in three
minutes oh no
so the karen at this point we're gonna
want to go up
here
yeah it's looking good layers i'm
layering you're layering
yeah
oh jeez this thing isn't working you're
right here you need this i do you can
take this
i'm a fair competitor
okay
i mean pretty much done i feel like
at this point it's just uh
trimming the edges and such
no
can you show me the photo again okay
yeah here you go
okay so there's a big swoop here
right here that now i think i just need
to style
it yeah you let it you need that front
swoop do i need a i have a do we have a
blow dryer mom yes we do i i
oh it's over there it's not plugged we'd
have no time for shenanigans
i'm doing a swoop now short in the back
perfection we got a swoop
we need a little shorter here
there you go
let's do a swoopy here
i think i'm on to something
like where's your swoop mom you're
here
how much time she got
uh unfortunately i think we only have
about a minute left a minute mom a
minute
this is impossible not for me
i think my karen is coming pretty
perfectly i mean
i'm kind of done
that's pretty good right i mean that's
pretty good let's see the back
let's not let's see the back
yeah it looks great
all right do a countdown
uh yeah uh are you done ten
nine
eight
seven
six
five four
three
two okay wait and fun mom here turn that
off yeah
okay here's what i'm gonna do for you
i'm gonna give you one opportunity
my dad is literally can you show to my
dad
cut to my dad
cut to my dad what are you doing
what are you doing
you're watching a youtube video we're
doing a show
okay i'm not playing a critical role
here you uh we could we can hear it
filming audio you're literally you're
sitting like 10 feet away from me
listening to a youtube video
how do you think that we can't hear you
it's not a youtube video
what is it let's probably buy this car
okay but like i didn't expect you to do
it right here go go i mean we can hear
you on the phone
you can have a phone call right there
you have a mic right in front of you
my bad okay
so anyway um all right
my dad's just sitting there with the
speaker all the way up
okay well well my then my mom is taking
i'm talking to my dad and my mom is
taking full advantage wait stop stop
here's what i'm gonna allow you to do
here's what i'm gonna allow you to do
what
you get one more cut you get one cut you
get one cut at this that's impossible
okay well you get one snip one one snip
is it and then you're out oh my god
that's all you get okay so make it
happen now or never oh my god this is
impossible
one snip
there's one cut left oh you've
decapitated your model
all right
is my dad doing it in the hallway my dad
i could hear you on the phone here he's
just in the hallway he's right here dad
i can hear it gary what's the matter
with you
go upstairs for christ's sake for
goodness sake
such a
boomer right one cut here's the cut this
is impossible you make that one cut
count all right
dad i can still hear it
i can't hear it well you're deaf all
right one cut come on oh lord
one cut
my fingers can't hold all this hair oops
all right come on stop stop stop milking
it one decision
[Music]
okay all the way
once your scissors down tension is
palpable once the scissors down you're
it that's it that's it wait whoa
finish the cut go all the way
knuckles
well so be it well that's not the way it
works dedication to the craft it means
cutting your hand oh my god okay you're
done back it up
lord
all right dan and ian i guess you guys
will be the judges of who's karen
i don't know that you get to do all this
well i have to call it i have to comb
her hair okay you have 30 seconds to
comb
30 seconds to comb
10 seconds left
yes that was quick 20 right there i'm
over it i don't want to watch my mob
comb see then all i have to do is cut
this this no no no no no no no
i missed this piece when i was cutting
all right here we go so here's the karen
we were going after uh-huh here's mine
mom do the stop it all right
there that's the side
you know i was skeptical of donna's
until she turned it around but um i
think she kind of got it i kind of yeah
actually my mom nailed it actually that
looks good even i wouldn't even hate
that's like a nice looking karen
actually oh it's horrible well it
obviously you need a little more time
but um i feel like it's
i mean yours doesn't really even say
karen to me yours looks more like uh
like a um
punk living in portland oregon yeah kind
of a trendy dewey yeah yours looks like
a lawnmower ran over her head right that
is kind of close to what actually
happened
my mom meanwhile is still cutting no i'm
still kidding it's in her bones what can
you say you won
all right well my mom give it up for
donna
let's go
[Applause]
he's already standing up my old
colleague saw this this is five minutes
my mother
mastered the dome
perfected the karen
wow and you are the reigning champion
not bad so take a bow five minutes ah
all right thank you yeah you beat me
don't anyone see this this is
these are really good gloria heads
though yeah those are nice
gloria heads yeah that we use are they
called gloria's yeah we used to call
them gloria heads who's gloria i don't
know someone that they named the thing
oh after
glory ahead
and yes hers really does have the camera
i'm i'm getting it damn okay mom she's
flex on me just michael jordan me in my
own
studio you know if i had time
all right everybody thank you we're not
here to actually watch a haircut okay
all right thank you everybody for
watching families
thank you mom thank you dad my dad is
still in the hallway he said thank you
it's always fun
all right we'll see you next week guys
well we'll see you on uh i want to bring
her home thursday and friday we got more
apps coming this week so we'll see you
then thanks guys ciao
[Music]
you